oh
[Musique]
il
quand une 106 n'y a qu'elle a un point
noir sur sur sa main par exemple c'est
ça veut dire qu'elle est en situation de
violence voire en danger
évidemment il peut y avoir des
situations d'urgence sony pour lequel la
n17 va être nécessaire mais aussi
parfois être amené à rendre une
situation encore une chose par des
interventions qui serait pas adapté donc
ça veut dire qu'il faut pouvoir
s'entourer de professionnels
si c'est une femme que l'on connaît on
peut très bien par exemple appeler le 39
19 ou des associations locales pour voir
avec elle de voilages et j'ai se signale
la banque doit voilà qu'elle est là la
meilleure conduite à tenir pour qu'ils
puissent l'idée ça peut être simplement
le rampeau visite de pouvoir inviter
peut-être à se rendre le chef chez vous
de voile a essayé d'amener aussi des
prétextes pour qu'elle puisse sortir du
domicile
voilà de voir un petit peu dans quelle
situation on peut aussi être mieux
entouré de professionnels
on sait très bien que dans des
situations de violence par exemple
intervenir directement sur l'agresseur
va signaler à celui ci que son ex
compagne a parlé et donc ça pourrait
être être compliqué pour elle par la
suite
[Musique]
m
ces outils sont intéressants je pense à
la marche mais il faut pouvoir aussi se
rendre compte que dans chaque commune
dans tous les cas dans chaque
département et dispositifs très très
très adapté et pour pelé en tous les cas
les utiliser les solliciter y compris à
travers d'autres professionnels anthony
ça peut être mais ça fout la paix mis sa
petite-amie semaine scolaire
ça peut être voilà les professionnels
qui m'a sensibilisé à la question et qui
vont pouvoir ensuite appelé les services
concernés y compris évidemment les
services de secours si nécessaire
dans tous les cas je vais pouvoir
s'appuyer sur eux
[Musique]
non
si une femme ne peut pas appeler le fils
est qu'elle est en danger elle peut
aussi faire un sms au 114 qui est un
service qui destinait aux personnes
malentendantes et qui est utilisé pour
les secours et ça peut aussi permettre
aux aux professionnels qui sont derrière
csm est d'appeler les services de police
et de gendarmerie ou cassés mais bien
sûr il faut indiquer son adresse
indiquée en anglais on sait très bien
qu'un certain nombre de féministes sont
commis au moment de la séparation que la
séparation est une période à risque
qu'il faut préparer cette séparation
qu'il faut préparer le départ du
domicile et si une femme abandonnée
envisagé de se séparer et veut partir et
qu'elles montrent effectivement un
signal soit effectivement les proches
arrivent à se mettre en contact avec les
associations sont déjà d'être au fait de
la situation et qui elle-même vous
pouvoir rémunérer centre c'est une
chance soit effectivement à ce moment là
au pouvoir soit même appelé le 17 ou
faire un sms pour 114 en tous les cas
donné des informations à ses victimes
pour qu'elles puissent sortir de là me
lancer